President Trump has sent a series of
mixed messages this week first on gun
control he reportedly told the NRA s
chief executive on Tuesday that he will
not support universal background checks
for gun buyers the next day he told
reporters I have an appetite for
background checks we are going to be
doing background checks on the economy
he said Tuesday that a payroll tax cut
is something that we think about the
very next day he reversed course saying
I'm not looking at a tax cut now we
don't need it chief Washington
correspondent major Garrett is here to
help us look at this major good morning
good morning first let's talk about the
economy it is the White House that
behind closed doors is the White House
actually worried about the economy it is
worried about the economy six to twelve
months from now not now they look at
economic data and the president talks
about it all the time jobs wages it's 12
months ago we're close to an election
precisely that's why there is internal
concern about it and the White House is
most concerned about the psychology
around the economy and concerned about
trade and other disruptions that they
see six to 12 months right up to 2020
and the election what's problem what's
problematic for the White House it
doesn't know what to do it wants to talk
a good game publicly has no idea what to
do legislatively and it also knows that
as the president continues to bark at
the Federal Reserve that creates more
anxiety on Wall Street and among traders
who say if the economy is great why are
you screaming at the Federal Reserve and
why are you giving these mixed signals
that just create more uncertainty and
you know Anthony as well as I do
capital is not courageous in times of
uncertainty Capital does what seeks
Treasury bonds yes which is not
investing in new jobs new growth new
expansion business gets cautious when
they exact service and the president's
own erratic behavior around is creating
more of that tendency against his own
best interest and the White House
doesn't know what to do about that
erratic may be the word as well to
describe the president's positions on
gun control he has acknowledged that
there is a national emergency around gun
violence and he walked out all that's
appalling
exactly yeah any and he walked up to the
line of supporting meaningful background
checks meaningful his word but what does
that mean and will Congress take this up
when they were no one knows what it
means for president Trump no one knows
what it means on Capitol Hill no one
knows what it means either at the NRA
or in the advocacy groups who are
seeking more restrictions on guns the
president wants to do something White
House advisors keep telling me that he
doesn't know what that something is and
there are those within the president's
inner circle who fear one more mass
shooting and the president will be
blamed in totality for whatever this is
even though he's not to be blamed for it
they feel if he doesn't act on something
that looks to be responsive to this
moment in this sense of deep national
anxiety he will pay a steep political
price so on the politics on the policy
he wants to do something legislatively
it's difficult for executive branch
initiatives also very difficult because
they're not really relevant you need
legislation what can Congress do what
does Congress willing to do the
president doesn't have ideas and the
political matrix doesn't appear capable
Republican and Democrat if sorting and
Republicans aren't likely to move unless
they serve the Republicans in the House
are telling the president don't go down
this road those who want gun control
will never give you credit and those who
want you to be a strong Second Amendment
defender will turn against you if you go
down this road so he feels very trapped
we'll see what happens when Congress
comes back Andy now tonight the
president is heading to the g7 what are
you gonna be looking for there tensions
this is not a good environment the
European allies are feeling more and
more estranged from this country and
this administration not necessarily the
country so much but clearly this
administration and the whole Greenland
thing just intensifies that sense that
the president is again using the word
erratic and not in any way sympathetic
to this long decades this decades-long
standing between the United States and
Europe and so I don't a particular I
don't expect there's not going to be a
communique there's not going to be
anything that is more positive policy
standpoint achieved and then you have
the whole Russian question yeah and
that's unresolved and the president
advocacy for Russia without a resolution
of Ukraine tells the g7 nations he's
still more siding with them Russia
rather than them alright major thank you
very much
and in fact the double thanks because
you will be doing double duty you are
here but you can see more of major when
he anchors tonight CBS Evening News
yes defining summer stock down
[Laughter]